ich habe die weko conficker ist ein
der kran für kinder
wie zweite wohnungsmieter expected
papier
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das team ist ein markantes helden
so prognostiziert freuen und haben einen
sechsten initiative vor
die arbeiten sind voll die menschen
irgendwie mit windows 7 windows 7
die petition ist könnte wayne jackson 50
[Musik]
da pay-tv
herab
[Applaus]
euro beschert
montevideo
sie habe sex
die partie
[Musik]
so haben und herzlich willkommen zu zdf
heute live bei ihren live stream zu
aktuellen ereignissen und da schauen wir
heute mal ausnahmsweise nicht auf die
erde sondern ins weltall denn das ist
die bislang ambitionierteste mission der
nasa um zu erforschen ob es auf unserem
nachbarplaneten mars jemals leben
gegeben hat seit dem 30 juli 2020 war
die mars sonde jetzt unterwegs zu
unserem roten nachbarn mitten in der
panini ist diese rakete erfolgreich
gestartet worden allein das ist schon
ein erfolg muss man ja feststellen
471 millionen kilometer hat die sonder
seitdem zurückgelegt und in wenigen
minuten soll sie die atmosphäre des
planeten durchbrechen und dann wird es
ganz spannend denn das ist die heiße
phase der mars rover p6 evans wird sich
dann auf den weg richtung oberfläche
machen und dann wenige minuten später
soll er unten auf treffen und das ist
die große frage ob das klappt bis dahin
kann einiges schiefgehen
es kann am ende also auch ein
totalausfall werden die nächste halbe
stunde wird daher extrem spannend und
die gucken wir uns zusammen an mit
doktor daniela tisch planeten geologin
und fachfrau für den mars und nicole
schmitz planeten forscherinnen und co
wissenschaftlerinnen einer der rover
kameras weiter vom institut für
planetenforschung am deutschen zentrum
für luft und raumfahrt in köln ist auch
einen schönen guten abend
es ist jetzt bereits der fünfte
mars-rover der dort auf die oberfläche
auftreffen soll und dort forschen soll
was unterscheidet den jetzt die person
ist oder den pässe während sagt man den
oder die mich weiß gerade nicht also
diesem rover von den anderen ja der
woche ist der bislang weiteste
entwickelte rover den die nasa da
bisherigen geschickt hat da sind einige
neue technische finessen darauf da wird
ganz besonders dazu in der lage sein
noch spuren von leben zu suchen eine
absolute neuerung ist dass erstmals ein
rohr dazu in der lage ist proben
einzusammeln die später vom mars
hoffentlich zur erde zurückgebracht
werden
es wird ein kleiner helikopter dabei
sein das gab es vorher auch noch nie um
zu testen ob man bei den mars atmosphäre
überhaupt fliegen kann
und eine ganz besonders besondere
neuerung ist zum beispiel auch ein
instrument mit dem man aus dem co2 der
mars atmosphäre sauerstoff generieren
kann was vielleicht später mal für die
atmung von bemannten missionen oder auch
für treibstoff generierung nötig werden
könnte also das könnte wirklich ein
großer durchbruch werden wenn man zu
ihrer kollegin nicole schmitz rüber
schwenken mit unserer kamera dann würde
mich mal interessieren diese landung auf
dieser jetzt alle gemeinsam warten die
scheint ja doch eine ziemlich große
herausforderung zu sein was ist dann da
das problem und wie sicher sind sie dass
das klappt ja das ist schon ziemlich
riskant die kollegen bei der nasa
sprechen denn nicht umsonst von den
sieben minuten des schreckens ist habe
mir jetzt auch terror und das liegt
daran dass das ein höchst kompliziertes
manöver ist und vor allem dass dieses
höchst komplizierte manöver voll
autonomen durchgeführt werden
wir haben das problem dass die
marsatmosphäre sehr sehr dünn ist viel
dünner als die erdatmosphäre und
dementsprechend fällt er über sehr
schnell und er ist auch ziemlich schnell
auf dem boden angekommen muss abbremsen
von ungefähr 19.000 stundenkilometern
auf fast null innerhalb von sieben
minuten
das erfordert einige technische finessen
und das weitere problem was das ganze
auch noch sehr sehr riskant macht ist
dass die signallaufzeit die wir haben
oben die signale von den roma zu
empfangen sind elf minuten die landung
dauert aber nur sieben minuten
das bedeutet dass der kontrollraum nicht
eingreifen kann
wir werden also im prinzip wäre das
signal wir bekommen was darüber gelandet
ist tschuldigung dann wird das signal
bekommen dass der rover in die
atmosphäre des mars eintritt und dann
die sich minuten kommen bis zur landung
dann ist ja eigentlich schon längst
unten und wir wissen dann aber erst
später ob er gut angekommen ist oder
nicht jene frage gleich aus der
zuschauerschaft von elemente werden die
es live sehen so richtig hat frau
schmidt grad schon beantwortet ja und
nein irgendwie ja da habe ich noch mal
einhalten
wir sehen alles elf minuten zeit
verzögert wir werden aber mit diesen elf
minuten zeitverzögerung die eigentlichen
ereignisse dann tatsächlich in der in
fast echtzeit erleben also alles
passiert elf minuten vorher die
ereignisse kommen aber dann trotzdem
schlag für schlag das liegt daran dass
wir dass der rover während des abstiegs
seine signale schickt über einen
satelliten in mars orbit das wird heute
abend der mars reconnaissance orbiter
sein
diese beiden also rover plus mars
reconnaissance orbiter die können in
echtzeit kommunizieren und die
verzögerung aber zwischen dem mars
reconnaissance orbiter der die signale
an die erde schickt und erde sind elf
minuten sind heißt sie wären aber sobald
er das signal haben werden wir die
ereignisse dann auch schnell verfolgen
kann sind halt ein paar millimeter
zwischen uns und dem planeten
wir gucken uns jetzt mal genau an wie
das ablaufen soll wir haben eine kleine
max vorbereitet weil die nasa hat er
natürlich auch schon alles mit tollen
animationen aufbereitet so soll das
ungefähr aussehen gleich mit eintritt in
die marsatmosphäre beginnt das was die
raumfahrt ingenieure die sieben minuten
des schreckens nennen die raumsonde
drastisch abgebremst und dadurch
gleichzeitig extrem erhitzt auf bis zu
1300 grad celsius der mars-rover
befindet sich hinter einem hitzeschild
damit er nicht zu heiß wird weil das
abbremsen durch die atmosphäre noch
nicht ausreicht wird zusätzlich ein
überschall fallschirm geöffnet in höhe
von etwa elf kilometer 20 sekunden nach
dem öffnen des fallschirms trennt sich
das hitzeschild ab um noch langsamer zu
werden trennt sich per se wir uns in
einer höhe von etwa zwei kilometern vom
fallschirm und zündet acht triebwerke
eines jet packs es läuft die abstieg
stufe zum schluss kommt der sogenannte
sky kriens im einsatz bei einer
geschwindigkeit von nur noch 2,7 km h
und in etwa 20 metern per se wir ins an
kabeln herabgelassen beine und räder
werden im lande position gebracht 12
sekunden nach beginn des karnevals
presse wir uns auf dem mars auf
tja das sieht wirklich aus diesem film
wir sprechen darüber und begleiten das
ganze live mit doktor daniela tierisch
planeten geologin und nicole schmitz
planeten forscherinnen beim institut für
planetenforschung am deutschen zentrum
für luft und raumfahrt in köln
frau dr tisch was genau erhoffen sich
jetzt forscherinnen wie sie von dieser
mission spannende neue erkenntnisse
natürlich traurig also die sagen wo wir
das erste mal tatsächlich der lage
wirklich gezielt nach bio signaturen
also nach ehemaligen mikrobiellen leben
in diesen krater zu suchen da ist ein
sehr interessantes data das war ja
früher man einschlagskrater und mit in
dem bei einem see und in diesem wetter
vermutet man dass in sich in den
sedimenten diese zeichen von ehemaligen
leben besonders gut erhalten haben
könnten und so nah dran waren wir vorher
noch nie und dazwischen zu antworten
sache natürlich geht's können wir uns
erstmals ja das ist ja schon abgefahren
das überhaupt wissen dass es ein
einschlagskrater ist und das doch mal
wasser drin gewesen sein muss woher
wissen wir das denn
also das ist für uns wissenschaftler
eigentlich eine unserer leichtesten
übungen wir untersuchen den mars ja
schon seit jahrzehnten mit
satellitendaten die haben viele kameras
die um die mars fliegen und uns
detaillierte bilder davon schicken wir
haben auf diesen anbietern das sind eben
die mission die nun den mars fliegen
auch sogenannte spektrometer da drauf
und die geben uns aufschluss über die
mineralogische zusammensetzung der
gesteine die wir dort auf dem mars
finden und viele mineralien die wir da
finden sind doch auf der erde entstanden
und von denen wissen wir ganz genau
welche umweltbedingungen geherrscht
haben zu der zeit zu der die minerale
entstanden sind und in diesem krater in
diesem delta finden wir mineralogie
sehen die hydra visierte mineral also
wasserhaltige minerale und die entstehen
nur durch die verwitterung von
ursprünglichen gestein auf dem mars ist
es so als lava gestein vulkanisches
gestein mit wasser zu diesen ebenen ton
mineralen zum beispiel und daher wissen
war ganz gut wie dass es da mal relativ
lange viel wasser gab es und setzen die
werden die mineralien nicht entstanden
und wir wissen zum beispiel auch weil es
über die ph-werte gewässern diese
tonminerale zeigen uns den neutralen ph
wert an das ist auch eine gute passt gut
in die er mit super der suche bei einer
habilitierten freundlichen bedingungen
ganz gut rein und daher wissen wir ja
dass der mann sie war und das delta
selber ist auch ein wir nennen das
morphologischer beweis denn so ein delta
entsteht immer nur wenn ein fließendes
gewässer in einen see mündet in ein
stehendes gewässer und die mitgeführten
sedimente die der fluss transportiert in
diesem stehenden gewässer an der mündung
quasi abgelagert werden
das kennen wir von der erde das gibt es
eben auf dem mars auch sind schon
beeindruckend was sie einfach als
einfache übung bezeichnen daher würde
ihr schon aussteigen
aber das ganze wird hier noch die
komplexe frau schmitz die sind denn sie
beziehungsweise das deutsche zentrum für
luft und raumfahrt jetzt an dieser
mission beteiligt was haben sie da mit
beisteuern können
wir sind in wissenschaftsteam der
mission beteiligt und meine kollegen und
ich haben vor allem die aufgabe die
daten und aufnahmen also die bilder der
sogenannten mass kz wissenschaftlich zu
analysieren
dimas konzert ist eine 3d stereo kamera
die auf dem mars rover sitzt und dann
aus zwei metern höhe ungefähr uns
dreidimensionale panorama bilder rund um
den rund um das gelände liefern wird
und wir sind aber von anfang an auch in
die prozessierung der daten eingebunden
meine kollegen hier aus der abteilung
für sie bringen sich das besondere ein
und wir haben da eine langjährige
erfahrung in der prozessierung von
besonders stereo bilddaten
wir werden aber auch eng
zusammenarbeiten mit anderen kollegen
vom dlr die auch noch in der mission
eingebunden sind daher meine kollegin
aus dem nachbar institute aus dem
institut für optische
informationssysteme die ist
wissenschaftlich eingebunden in die
sogenannte super cam und das ist
wirklich ein super instrument das ist
ein laser spektrometer das sitzt auch
auf dem mast und es kann kontaktlos aus
der entfernung und die mineralogische
zusammensetzung von gestein liefern und
das messprinzip ist auch ganz spannend
da ist im prinzip ein laser der die
äußeren gesteinschichten verdampft und
dann kann man
aus dem entstehenden leuchtenden plasma
die mineralogie ableiten
und dann haben wir weitere kollegen die
einen mega beteiligt sind
wir erzählen sie ruhig weiter wir wollen
gucken wie es genau aussieht aber bitte
wir haben noch kollegen sind noch an
meter beteiligt das ist die
wetterstation auf dem rover die uns
täglich umweltbedingungen daten liefern
wir das umwelt daten liefern wird
temperaturen strahlung luft von
luftdruck und auf die staubbelastung und
das ist nicht nur aus wissenschaftlicher
sicht sehr interessant sondern das sind
auch wichtige daten die werke die sie
blockieren müssen und die wir brauchen
werden wenn wir später nahmen die
astronauten auf dem mars leben und
arbeiten wollen und was du jetzt
ziemlich etwas schwer vorzustellen ist
wenn man jetzt mal also so anhört haben
wir natürlich auch visualisiert doch das
eine schöne kleine animation die wir
euch jetzt gerne zeigen möchten
providence hat die größe eines
kleinwagens und wie knapp eine tonne an
bord sieben wissenschaftliche
instrumente darunter auch solche bei
deren datenauswertung experten des
deutschen zentrums für luft und
raumfahrt mitwirken wie die 3d kamera
masken set sie soll farbige 360 grad
panoramen des mars in 3d anfertigen die
supercomm ermöglicht spd sei die
chemische zusammensetzung von gestein
sand und staub zu bestimmen und dermaßen
weibel dynamics anna leiser kurz meter
misst mit einer reihe von sensoren unter
anderem temperatur windgeschwindigkeit
und windrichtung sowie die größe und
form von staub
also das wird ganz schön spannend alles
sehr hoch technisiert die kommen
ziemlich viele fragen von euch zum
genauen ablauf können sie uns doch mal
kurz noch ein update geben die das jetzt
genau ablaufen wird also wir gucken ja
schon auf die uhr es dauert nicht mehr
lange aber womit müssen jetzt rechnen um
welche uhrzeit das sollte eigentlich 21
8 30 eigentlich sollte die cruise days
schon abgetrennt sein das ist die reise
stufe mit der person zum mars gebracht
wurde
die nächste phase wäre jetzt dass der
rover sich bereit macht in die
marsatmosphäre einzutreten und dann die
sieben minuten des schreckens beginnen
würden das sollte ungefähr 21 48
passieren unserer zeit also erden zeit
quasi und dazwischen genau das heißt
wann wird die wird der rover hoffentlich
auf der marsoberfläche aufsetzen
also das ist ungefähr 21 55 also bis
dahin haben wir noch ein bisschen zeit
aber wir haben viele fragen zu
beantworten
keine frage hier gibt es ganz konkret
ich weiß nicht ob einer von ihnen beiden
die beantworten kann und zwar zu der
frage wie schwer ist dieser roboter und
was kostet diese ganze mission haben sie
da die zahl im kopf ja mehr oder schnitt
[Gelächter]
knapp eine tonne also 1000 48 kilogramm
ungefähr
die mission kostet waren 2,3 milliarden
und die der betrieb der mission jetzt in
der nominell mission in den 21 jahren
also eine mehr tja mit einem homerun
wird ungefähr bei 300 millionen liegen
also deutlich weniger als der bau selbst
ich habe aber mal gelesen die nasa hat
das mal runter gebrochen was das pro-
amerikanischen einwohner an kosten sind
und das sind zehn cent pro jahr oder so
ich weiß es nicht mehr als aber das ist
kein reden aber es ist nein sind es
nicht es ist die teuerste version die
die nasa
vielleicht kannst du kurz zeigen sie am
grab ist schon gezeigt sie haben da
erdnüsse stehen tatsächlich bei sich nur
warum
ja natürlich das erklärt frau schwierig
da es ist eine tradition bei der nasa
die stammt aus dem alten mond
ferienprogramm als die nasa versucht hat
die ersten paar male auf dem mond zu
landen hat es sieben anläufe gebraucht
bis ranger 7 dann erfolgreich war und
vor der landung von ranger 7 gab es im
kontrollraum erdnüsse und seitdem ist
das bei der nase einer tradition dass
bei allen kritischen manöver in science
landungen oder auch staat müsse da sein
müssen so die zeit rennt und zweck
hinter ihnen das ist auch schon der
countdown ist keine gute landung okay
ich gehe noch kurz zeit dass ich mal
vorbereiten was dort passiert und ich
schalte zu meiner kollegen nach münchen
zur tochter susanne ramm teil meiner thx
moderation school gehen astrophysiker
und angehende astronautin wir haben es
nicht mehr ganz so viel zeit zusammen
aber vielleicht kannst du mal kurz
erklären warum machen wir solche mission
eigentlich
ich glaube das ist ganz klar also
millionen von menschen verfolgen jetzt
diese landung hier gebannt bei den mond
an und machten sich noch sehr viel mehr
als ich glaube einfach dass die raubtat
exploration etwas ist was die menschheit
begeistert und das macht uns irgendwie
auch zu menschen dass wir immer weiter
hinaus räumen dass er immer mehr wissen
wollen über unsere nachbar planeten über
unser sonnensystem und wir unsere
galaxie und so weiter also ich finde es
immer natürlich hat es jetzt keinen
direkten nutzen unbedingt für die
probleme die wir jetzt da auf der erde
haben
aber es macht und eben zu menschen immer
mehr erfahren zu wollen und in den
weltraum hinausgehen sollen
und was hat es mit dem mars auf sich ich
meinen wir gucken ja schon seit
jahrzehnten immer auf diesen roten
planeten und fragen uns ob es da
irgendwie kleine grüne männchen gibt
warum gerade der war ja gut die
kleineren mensch männchen können wir
jetzt glaube ich ausschließen inzwischen
aber es ist einfach so der mars ist sehr
nah an uns dran also die sonne jetzt per
sibiriens hat ungefähr sechseinhalb
monate nur gebraucht um dahin zu kommen
wenn man jetzt zu den weiter entfernten
planeten fahren möchte dann dauert das
jahre
und natürlich ist der mars auch noch in
der habitablen zone also das heißt am
äquator hat man tagsüber temperaturen
von bis zu plus 20 grad celsius
also das sind durchaus sind auch
temperaturen natürlich es ist kühl als
auf der erde
aber es sind durchaus temperaturen wo
man sich noch irgendwie leben vorstellen
könnte ich muss mal kurz in die regie
fragen wie viel zeit haben wir noch
stefan eine minute dann so sagen ja noch
ganz kurz die frage würdest du auf den
mars fliegen und dann versuchen den zu
kolonisieren also ich werde tatsächlich
auf den mars fliegen definitiv das war
schon als kind immer mein traum ich
wollte mir die erste frau auf dem mars
werden aber zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
glaube ich nur mit rückfahrticket gut
das können wir noch nicht garantieren
bis die menschen dort oben ankommt wird
noch ein bisschen zeit vergehen wir
werden gucken dass wir nachher noch ein
paar fragen beantworten weil das sind
wirklich sehr auch sehr dezidierte
fragen aber ich möchte gern noch mal zu
den beiden forscherinnen nach köln
schalten ins deutsche zentrum für luft
und raumfahrt denn jetzt geht
tatsächlich der countdown los wir nähern
uns 21 uhr 48 und da beginnt jetzt die
heiße phase
frau schmitz können sie noch mal
erklären was da jetzt genau passieren
wird
wir haben jetzt eine minute 18 und
counting bis zum eintritt in die
atmosphäre und der rover wird mit dem
mit dem hitzeschild zuerst in die
atmosphäre eintreten mit ungefähr
geschwindigkeit waren so knapp 19.000
kilometern pro stunde
er hat ein kleines triebwerke die ihnen
die helfen ihnen auf kurs zu halten
es kann natürlich sein dass er auf
luftlöcher drückt also auf unterschiede
in der in der dichte der marsatmosphäre
und oft turbulenzen
er hat aber autonom steuerungssysteme
die da jede abweichung vom zielkorridor
sofort korrigieren
der nächste punkt wäre dann das war ein
manöver haben namen straighten up and
flight das ist noch mal so wie letzte
richtige ausrichtung auf den ziel
bringen dann würde sich der fallschirm
des rovers öffnen
die sonne einfach weiter abzugrenzen
weil diese eine atmosphärische entweder
das reicht nicht aus gibt es da
eigentlich atmosphäre auf dem mars die
das komplizierte verkomplizieren könnte
also stürme zb das heißt das risiko ist
schon mal ausgeschlossen
jetzt gibt es auch fragen wann wir live
bilder bekommen vom mars das kann ich
euch tatsächlich gerade nicht
beantworten aber wir sind auch das
signal von der nasa angewiesen die uns
gerade dass wir über schickt was ihr
sehen könnt
frau schmitz was sehen wir da eigentlich
genau
gerade minute nachdem was eben gerade
dass der rover tatsächlich jetzt in
seiner in seiner kapsel in die
atmosphäre eintritt
das passiert gerade jetzt
so wie das da ist das ist ist das ein
live ticker das ist eine animation
das sieht nicht mehr hören jetzt der
kontrollraum
darauf reagiert der kontrollraum hat
natürlich die signale
genau wie gesagt das ist der flug ist
durch die atmosphäre der hofer ist immer
noch verdammt schnell die kleinen
triebwerke die ihnen jetzt auf kurs
halten in dieser phase die ihnen genau
die kleinen steuer triebwerke hat
richling jetzt perfekt auch den
landepunkt aus hier ist eine frage was
wäre wenn jetzt das ganze ja tatsächlich
schief geht muss das ganze neu gestartet
werden und wenn ja mit welchem geld also
müsste man noch mal von vorne anfangen
richtige hand ist will wissen darüber
wäre natürlich dann verloren wenn er
abstürzt wäre wahrscheinlich gar nicht
mal das weiß was sonst passiert hier auf
den genau das ist ja auf den moment wenn
sich nicht viel ich sage ihnen bescheid
was passiert also auch band war stille
im nasa kontrollzentrum
alle schauen auf die messinstrumente wir
haben auch gerade bei der nasa bild
unten so kleine geschwindigkeitsmesser
gesehen und man genau sehen konnte wie
schnell die sonne gerade ist ich hoffe
das bild kommt gleich noch mal wieder
und wir sind jetzt gerade mitten in
diesen sieben minuten des schreckens
verschmitzt über gründliche unten in der
anzeige
wir sind gerade bei ein paar korrektur
manöver
wir warten darauf dass es gibt eine
technologie jetzt namens range trigger
die den optimalen zeitpunkt ermittelt
werden der fallschirm ausgelöst wird und
[Musik]
das hitzeschild das muss noch
abgesprengt werden nachdem nach dem ja
man muss halt eine gewisse dichte der
atmosphäre erreichen deswegen geht es
erst relativ spät weil die mars
atmosphäre so billig ist das kann schon
eine information dass die atmosphäre ein
text in langsam erreicht wurde so viel
konnten jetzt schon was kann denn da
alles schief gehen können sich öffnen
deshalb gab es schon alle möglichen
probleme da gab es mal verkabelungs
fehler software-fehler einmal haben die
sensoren gesagt dass da wo wir schon auf
dem grund ist dabei waren noch 20 meter
über der oberflächen oder 40 und ist
dann abgestürzt weil die raketen
ausgeschaltet hat das weiß man vorher
nicht aber die amerikaner sind auf alles
vorbereitet
sie sind die die wärme die
erfolgreichsten sendungen bisher in der
geschichte der raumfahrt vollbracht und
haben aus ihren fehlern gelernt haben
die dinge die
noch nicht perfekt war perfektioniert so
es wird geklatscht habe ich gesehen was
ist der grund weshalb man applaudiert
hat die kann ich gar nicht sein aber
links hier im bildschirm sehen wir zum
beispiel die verschiedenen stufen die
erste abgearbeitet werden müssen wenn
ich das richtig verstehen sind die stufe
17 von optisch und technisch in dieses
manöver was ich eben erwähnt habe das
straighten up and fly right während sich
das ist eine perfekte ausrichtung auf
den zielpunkt und wir hören gerade das
der fall schon ausgelöst
überschattet fallschirm
das heißt das genau wir haben aber jetzt
unter unter 1 macht er wird bei
überschallgeschwindigkeit ausgelöst und
dann darf man aber natürlich die nächste
stufe wäre jetzt das hitzeschild
abgesprengt
danach besteht abgetrennten das wäre
dann der punkt ab denen dann auch kamera
und mikrofone und die andere instrumente
von dem rover aufzeichnen können und an
dem auch das radar das navigationssystem
starten werden
das scheint zu haben jetzt muss es
schnell gehen damit es bis jetzt noch
gar nicht an die nation system aktiven
wir ermitteln jetzt anhand der umgebung
unter anderem auf den aktuellen den
richtigen kurs um den exakten landepunkt
für den rohbau das passiert alles voll
autonomen dieses mal das ist eine der
neuerungen dieser lande bei diesem lande
man genau das ist jetzt gerade das
navigationssystem was einen guten landet
um gefunden hat die bachelor ist aber
das heißt der fall schon bis jetzt weg
das heißt wir haben jetzt in die
brandboxx kein aktiv und die bremsen
jetzt immer weiter ab und jetzt wäre der
nächste schritt an dass das sky train
man über ungefähr 20 tage bei der
oberfläche wir müssen jetzt weniger als
fünf kilometer vom landepunkt entfernt
sein ja
das heißt wie lange noch und da wird
gejubelt wenige sekunden weniger
angefangen dass der hunger wird jetzt an
langen kabel durch den boden abgeseilt
ich glaube das ist noch nicht alles
klappen noch nicht noch nicht noch
nächsten setzten aber wir sind kurz
davor um halb zehn uhr die räder sind
ausklappt der rover ist kurz vom boden
[Musik]
und dann hat man es geschafft
[Applaus]
tja
dass der mars rover auf der oberfläche
sicher angekommen ist passieren müssen
damit das funktioniert das ist ich bin
wieder mal extrem eindruck
und dessen auch mal wieder jetzt warten
wir auf das erste bild kino also es
wurde uns versprochen dass nach einer
minute das erste bild kommen könnte das
wird allerdings sehr verschwommen das
bild sein weil auf den kameras so
schutzkappen drauf sind die natürlich
bei dem ganzen staub der aufgewirbelt
wird
die kameras linsen beschädigen könnten
und die ist natürlich noch drauf aber
eine dieser hess camps ist es glaube ich
die jetzt bald das erste bild schießen
wird und das wird man heute noch sehen
ich glaube die anderen bilder die
brauchen ein bisschen länger automatisch
aufgelöst habe genau die werden dann
später abgesprengt abgelöst aber das
macht man erst die nächsten tagen stück
für stück das sind ja 19 kameras 23
insgesamt aber die anderen braucht man
jetzt nicht mehr genau und die sind alle
mit so einer schutzkappe versehen das
aber üblich so also braucht man sich
jetzt nicht wundern wenn das bild ein
bisschen unscharf ist hauptsache es
kommt 1 und wird halt ich denke mal im
blick auf den boden kurz vor dem rover
zeigen da wird man nicht sehr viel sehen
vielleicht ein paar steinchen oder so
viel staub
ich habe
schauen sie mal frau doktor tief
verankerten bild nasa screen ist schon
ein thema gewesen
[Musik]
ich habe kein geld im lande noch nicht
gesehen haben
[Musik]
das ist für uns wissenschaftliche
sensation in den zuschauer ist
vielleicht weniger beeindruckt aber
glauben sie mir die beeindruckenden
bilder gewähren aufkommen ich kann ihnen
sagen dass sie sich tausende zuschauer
gerade haben ich glaube das sind vielen
menschen draußen gerade dieses schon
sehr beeindruckend finden also da müssen
sie sich sorgen machen dass das
interessiert viele menschen das ist
schon wirklich ein besonderer augenblick
der herren sehr gespannt was das für
ergebnisse bringen wird ich habe ja noch
ein paar fragen von unseren zuschauern
[Musik]
das sind kameras vorne angebrachten
wissenschaftlichen kameras die auf dem
mast sitzen die können noch nicht
aufnehmen denn der macht ist noch ein
geklappt genau deswegen hat man jetzt
leicht schräge sich nach unten und es
ist so ein bisschen aus wie ein frisch
auge weil das eben so eine kamera sind
ihnen möglichst weiten blickwinkel haben
sollen deswegen das ist jetzt sich die
krümmung des maßes sind die man da sieht
sondern sieht es eher so eine fischaugen
optik und die ist dazu da wie sie gerade
sagten hesse freut uns also um gefahren
zu vermeiden oder zu identifizieren ja
das ist eine kamera kamera die wir auch
mit oder die kollegen bei der nasa auch
mit zur hindernis umfahrung benutzen
genau davon gibt es zwei eine arme
vorderen teil ist was dem einen die nach
hinten schaut der rover hat ja ein
autonomes system quasi an bord um sein
und kann mit den vielen kameras seine
umgebung ganz genau bewerten betrachten
und dann autonom guten selbst berechnen
was natürlich den arbeitsaufwand von
vielen von der bodenstation minimiert
und auch für spätere bemannte missionen
genutzt werden soll dass er immer
gewisse strecken alleine fahren kann
da wissen die vielen kameras eben auch
wirklich ich habe mir eine frage die
finde ich so spezifische stellen muss
wissen wie sie der wunde energie
versorgt wird solar oder auch mit radio
club batterie mit radioisotope
generatoren von seinem leiden wie meine
kurz erklärt der zerfall von isotopen
wird goutiert werden und die wird
genutzt um ideen zu kommentieren
das war kurz und knackig eine weitere
frage kommt aus der community wieder
roboter mit der erde kommuniziert wird
das weiterhin jetzt über satelliten
passieren
hauptsächlich ja der rover kann
theoretisch auch über ex bahnhof direkt
mit der erde kommunizieren aber das
funktioniert natürlich nur wenn die erde
sozusagen der sichtachse ist auf auf das
lange auf die lange stelle oder auf die
stelle wo sich darüber gerade befindet
ansonsten kommunizieren wir
hauptsächlich über sogenannte raleigh
satelliten zum beispiel der mars
reconnaissance orbiter
da wird aber auch der trays gas orbiter
genutzt das sind europäische satellit da
ist also auch wieder zusammenarbeit
internationale zusammenarbeit alles was
an satelliten in mars orbit verfügbar
ist wird auch für in raleigh benutzt und
genau das wird der haupt modus der
kommunikation sein
also ich würde ihnen das gerne in kurzen
augenblick zum durchatmen geben weil wir
haben auch noch einen beitrag
vorbereitet wo mein kollege jan fischer
noch mal genauer erklärt hat was dort
der mars rover auf dem mars alles
ocean soll gab es jemals leben auf dem
mars in diesen krater auf dem roten
planeten soll der hightech rover presse
wir uns jetzt nach antworten suchen das
besondere das ausgewählte suchgebiet ist
reich an biologischer vielfalt und sah
vor mehr als dreieinhalb milliarden
jahren wohl noch gänzlich anders aus
der girocard ist deswegen besonders
interessant weil er mal die stelle eines
alten sees war und in diesem sind
materialien rhein transportiert und von
einem fluss die besonders vielfältig
sind
läuft alles nach plan der perser wir uns
schon in einigen tagen mit seiner ganz
speziellen mission beginnen
denn das rollende labor sollen nicht nur
neue daten gewinnen sondern auch proben
einsammeln
an den britischen arzt außerdem ein
kleiner schlagbohrer befestigt der mit
einem durchmesser von ein paar
zentimetern richtige bohrkerne sensitive
von 10 20 zentimeter nehmen kann
und die werden dann einerseits an bord
untersucht und andererseits in
bestimmten kleines metallröhrchen
eingeführt die werden dann hermetisch
versiegelt und dann in form von
sammelbehältern auf der marsoberfläche
abgelegt die bleistift großen
gesteinsproben sollen dann in zukunft
abgeholt und zur analyse auf die erde
gebracht werden ein einmaliger vorgang
doch personals kann auch mehr voll
gepackt mit neuester technik und
instrumenten ist es für den rover
möglich die umwelt zu erforschen und
bemannte mars mission vorzubereiten
außerdem hat er einen mini helikopter an
bord mit dem erstmals flugtests in der
extrem dünne atmosphäre des planeten
durchgeführt werden sollen
ja also eine ganze menge forschung die
dieser ungefähr pkw große rover erfüllen
kann vollautomatisch haben wir heute
schon gelernt frau doktor tisch da
werden jetzt bis zu 38 behälter glaube
ich befüllt die werden abgelegt und
frühestens in zehn jahren abgeholt
ist das nicht furchtbar lange zeit für
eine wissenschaftlerin aus zug ab zu
warten bis man die proben tatsächlich
untersuchen kann
ja das stimmt das ist natürlich das
kommt ein sicherlich noch länger als
zehn jahre vor aber wir haben in den
zehn jahren ja auch zu tun also isst
braucht jetzt so lange bis die bis diese
mission manager sample return mission
irgendwann abgeschlossen ist das
geschafft man ja nicht indem man da
einfach hinfliegt die proben nimmt und
wieder wieder zurückfliegt das ist
technisch nicht möglich das muss in
vielen etappen passieren
und die ziehen sich eben über viele
jahre nicht zuletzt weil man eben nur
alle zwei jahre zum mars fliegen kann
also erde und mars entfernt sich ja
immer wieder voneinander und nur alle 26
monate sind so ungefähr nur 656
millionen kilometer und dann ist ihnen
dieses staates fenster und deswegen ist
das nächste erst 2022 und dann 24 26 und
es ist jetzt in planung
dass die dass es einen kleinen eine
mission geben wird da wird ein kleiner
rover der die proben einsammeln wird der
nennt sich vetsch rover der wird von der
esa gestellt die probe zu einem
funktionalen attraktive sage ich mal
bringen wird sie wird von der nasa
gestellt und diese rakete schießt diese
diesem typus will ich als proben drin
sind in die maas in die maas umlaufbahn
und dann wird später also dann in einer
dritten phase ist das dann schon ein
kleines raumschiff gegen wie so ne art
raumfähre die wird die proben einsammeln
also aufnehmen vollautomatisch wird sie
wieder hermetisch in seinem inneren
versiegeln und dann zur erde fliegen und
dort auf der erde kontrolliert in der
wüste von utah abstürzen lassen
und das dauert eben moniert und das wird
einfach mehr 2000 dreißiger jahren sein
wenn wir glück haben wir haben aber auch
in der geschichte der mars forschung
gelernt dass mission immer wieder mal
verschoben werden
und wenn es schlecht läuft eben gleich
um zwei jahre und deswegen kann man
nicht genau sagen genommen das geht aber
wir wieder persönlich haben wir derzeit
natürlich noch ganz andere dinge zu tun
denn unsere eigene exomars mission die
ebene auch nach leben auf dem mars
suchen wird startet im jahr 2022 wir
wollen im juli 2023 ankommen und dann
haben wir alle hände voll zu tun und
können uns die zehn jahre mit
wunderbaren maß daten um die ohren
schlagen und es wird definitiv nicht
langweilig
das glaube ich auch eine sehr
spezifische frage oder die find ich auch
sehr interessant vielleicht an dem sie
vielleicht können sie die beantworten wo
ist das wasser hin möchte christian auf
youtube wissen dass früher in so großen
mengen auf dem markt gewesen sein muss
wissen wir dass diese zeit haben sie
denn so informiert das ist nicht was
auch schön also das wasser auf dem mars
ist zu einem großteil in das all und
hunden nach dem was man heute weiß
und zwar zum beispiel durch also das war
ja eine atmosphäre auch vorhanden in
form von wasserdampf und wenn da diese
vielen und daher diese vielen asteroiden
und meteoriteneinschläge stattgefunden
haben ist unheimlich viel material vom
mars in das all katapultiert wurden und
da gibt es in wien nicht nur gesteine
dabei sondern auch atmosphäre und damit
auch eine ganze menge wasser um das ist
eher eine prozess der andere prozess ist
dass es tatsächlich heute noch relativ
viel wasser auf dem mars gibt aber in
form von eis weil wasser heute nach rein
physikalisch nicht mehr flüssig sein
kann der luftdruck ist zu gering ist
immer viel zu kalt also selbst wenn es
mal wärmer wird wir haben davon gehört
werden auch einfluss gerade auf dem mars
dann wird das sofort gasförmig das heißt
das wasser eis ist auf dem mars gebunden
in den polkappen es gibt zwei große
polkappen offenbar sind mehrere
kilometer dick die bestehen aus einer
mischung aus co2 ein wassereis nord und
südpol und wir wissen relativ sicher
auch das wahnsinnig viel wasser im boden
also als boden eis noch gespeichert ist
es gab im zvei im jahre 2008 meine
länder missionen die hieß phoenix das
war so ein kleiner ändert er hatte so
länder ist ein gefährt auf maß was nicht
unfair sondern da steht um vor ort seine
untersuchungen
der hatte so einen kleinen bagger an
dabei und er hat eines tages hat der so
ein bisschen die oberste bodenschicht
weggekratzt und darunter ist hinweis
weißes und dieses weise ist nach einer
zeit verschwunden und er wusste man
sofort man hat ja danach gesucht das ist
eis was sublimiert eben sofort verdampft
ist oder nach einer weile verdampft ist
und es war dann der tatsächliche beweis
für das boden eis was man vorher schon
durch untersuchungen mit orbitern
vermutet hat und die andere wasser senke
ist quasi sind die minerale wir finden
sehr viele wasserhaltige minerale auf
dem mars die viel wasser gebunden haben
es gibt noch ein bisschen wasserdampf
aber das sind unter null komma ich weiß
nicht mal 0,3 prozent oder so oder 0,03
prozent das ist verschwindend gering
ja das sind die prozesse von denen wir
heute wissen wo das wasser hier ist also
die frage hätten wir beantwortet vielen
dank frau doktor tisch und verschmitzt
dass sie heute abend mit uns zusammen
quasi sich diese mission angeschaut
haben die kokons noch mal die bilder an
vom kontrollraum wie dort gejubelt wurde
bei der nasa als der mars rover
experience sicher gelandet ist auf der
oberfläche
da gibt es große freude
ja also das hat glücklicherweise
funktioniert große erleichterung bei der
nasa im kontrollraum in pandemie zeiten
gibt es nur einen film und keine
umarmung
aber die erdnüsse scheinen ihre wirkung
gezeigt zu haben die es dort
traditionellerweise immer gibt wie ich
heute abend auch gelernt habe
so und der spreche ich noch mal einer
kollegin dr susanne randal thx
moderatorin und wahrscheinlich auch sehr
erleichtert oder total also es war hoch
emotional wir haben hier im studio
natürlich auch mitgefiebert und ich habe
mich vor allem total gefreut zu sehen
wie die beiden wissenschaftlerinnen vom
dlr sich auch gefreut haben wie
erleichtert ja auch waren es ist halt so
auf dem mars zu land ist relativ
schwierig ist wie schon angesprochen
also nur er zwischen 40 und 50 prozent
aller mission waren überhaupt
erfolgreich gerade die länder sind sehr
sehr sehr sehr schwierig dort sicher und
herunterzubringen und ich hatte
tatsächlich mein kumpel der für die
dicke mission gearbeitet hat und der
musste und ich habe mit zugeschaut da
mussten wir ansehen wie eben der
funkkontakt verloren gegen und am ende
dann hegel verloren war
das heißt ich will auch sehr sehr
erleichtert hier gibt es einige fragen
zu der mission oder zumindest auch zu
dem was noch folgen wir zum beispiel von
stefan findet meister auf facebook der
möchte wissen ist das ganze schon eine
vorbereitung für eine mission mit
astronauten
da würde ich sagen also definitiv und
das finde ich persönlich als astronaut
10 anwärterin auch wahnsinnig spannende
missionen
es gibt tatsächlich einige buhs of
concept experimente also das heißt es
gibt zum beispiel maxi und das heißt so
es wurde vorher kurz angesprochen das
ist eben ein experiment wo gesehen
werden soll ob man aus dieser sehr sehr
dünnen co2 atmosphäre oder hauptsächlich
co2 atmosphäre der maas hat sauerstoff
beginnen kann und das ist so wichtig
nicht nur für astronauten damit sie dann
eben auch sauerstoff zum atmen haben wer
schön sondern auch dafür dass mit
irgendwann ja wenn man astronauten zum
mars schickt die idealerweise auch
wieder hoch in den orbit und dann wieder
zurück zur erde bringen möchte und so
eine rakete auf dem mars wurde würde
ungefähr 27 tonnen sauerstoff brauchen
und den dann mitzuschleppen von der erde
bis zum mars natürlich relativ schwierig
deswegen schaut man jetzt eben mit
dieser maxime ist ein experiment ob man
eben sauerstoff gewinnen könnte für den
rücktransport eventueller astronautinnen
zur erde
es gibt ja auch noch skeptische fragen
haben wir am anfang auch schon mal kurz
thematisiert ich sage mal als beispiel
pokerface auf youtube der möchtet wissen
kann man ja nicht erst mal die probleme
hier auf der
den griff kriegen bevor man auf dem mars
rund kriechen muss was kommt als
nächstes urlaub auf dem jupiter ein
hotel auf dem saturn
es gibt aber auch und das ist dann eher
der hammermühle auf youtube den
kommentar das ist ein großer schritt in
richtung besiedlung des mars 2050 soll
sich ja circa einer million menschen
dort aufhalten können ist das
tatsächlich schon so sicher dass wir mal
irgendwann dort leben könnten
nein also ich halte es nicht für sicher
dass wir irgendwann gut irgendwann kann
man sehr weit fassen innerhalb der
nächsten 50 jahre weiß ich nicht also
die nasa ist jetzt wenn sie optimistisch
ist geht sie von einer landung auf dem
mars definitiv nicht vor 2030 also mit
astronautinnen aus ich denke es wird in
der raumfahrt ist es immer so alles
verschiebt sich immer nach hinten also
ich würde jetzt sagen realistischerweise
sind reden wir von 2035 2040 und
wirklich die ersten menschen die dann
vielleicht zum mars kommen könnten und
von dort dass da wirklich einfach mal
ein mensch rumläuft vielleicht einen
monat bleibt zwei monate bleibt je nach
dem bis zu einer permanenten besiedlung
des mars ich glaube da ist noch ein
weiter weg gehen also das würde mich
wundern wenn wir das innerhalb von 50
jahren schaffen zusammen nach vielen
dank für deine einschätzungen und für
dein wissen ich möchte natürlich noch
mal darauf hinweisen es gibt von terrex
von unserer wissenschaftsredaktion viele
tolle dokumentationen zum mars
rätselhafte wüsten welt zum beispiel wie
beliebt meine mission zum mars
der mars mission und fakten einfach mal
google-suche anschmeißen oder bei uns in
der zdf mediathek gucken da gibt es dann
sehr sehr viel zu lernen
so seien für heute abend vielen dank und
wir sind froh dass alles gut gegangen
ist ja jetzt feiern wir oder absolut
hast du auch erdnüsse da ich habe
tatsächlich ich weiß nur dass schleiche
ich habe tatsächlich eine messbar da wir
haben gedacht das passt einfach so
schneiden wir raus können wir nicht ist
der live-schalte susanne unterscheiden
das noch mal ganz kurz zurück nach köln
ins deutsche zentrum für luft und
raumfahrt zu unseren beiden
forscherinnen ist denn jetzt noch in den
letzten minuten was spannendes passiert
jetzt schon etwas neues
wir haben ihnen tatsächlich gerade ganz
gespannt zugehört und ich habe nicht
wirklich den leistung verfolgt aber ich
glaube nicht dass jetzt gerade nochmal
spannend
ich hatte immer ein auge darauf ja es
wurden viele interviews geführt viele
erleichterte gesichter jetzt wird gerade
ein bisschen erzählt wieso die der
nächste plan aussieht es wird gerade
gerade auch die mögliche route gezeigt
die der übernehmen soll
aber neue erkenntnisse wie jetzt von der
von nach der landung selbst mich das
sind mehr so hintergrund informationen
und eindrücke sie gerade gezeigt wurden
wird wird in der oper wird
wahrscheinlich aber nur in diesen in
diesem delta unterwegs seien maximal
nicht unbedingt also wenn wenn alles gut
geht wir haben ja gelernt dass so eine
mars-mission meistens viel länger
durchhalten als sie eigentlich
ursprünglich sollten also was ist ja
immer erst mal für eine bestimmte
nominelle mission ausgelegt ist es
werden hier zwei erdenjahre ein maß ja
aber wenn alles gut geht um genug zeit
ist ein fetter hoffe natürlich immer
weiter also wenn er dennoch funktioniert
und wenn die asse nasa immer wieder die
mission verlängert und die gelder
bereitstellt und dann würde man aus dem
krater heraus eine route gen westen
wählen in richtung dieses tals und
außerdem das data entstanden ist und
dort einen weg aus dem krater heraus in
das benachbarte hochland flachland
nehmen und dort noch ganz andere gestein
untersuchen können im data selber kann
man vulkanische gesteine und ihm diese
wasserhaltigen minerale untersuchen und
je weiter man raus kommt desto eltern
werden die gesteine da kann man sich zum
beispiel auch gesteine anschauen die
durch den einschlag dieses großen
einschlags beckers leben des oro also
und liegt am rand eines großen
einschlags becken das heißt sie das
planet ja und das ist vor 3,9 milliarden
jahren entstanden
und während des einschlags sind ganz
gespannt gesteine auch entstanden und
die würde man gerne untersuchung und die
geben nochmal viel mehr aufschluss und
einblick in die frühe geschichte des
mars das würde mal machen wenn es denn
klappt und ansonsten macht man eben so
weit wie man kommt das heißt wir können
auch damit rechnen dass die nächsten
jahre doch immer noch bilder und
informationen zu uns kommen hier gibt es
eine frau
dazu den bildern einmal wie viele also
wird es noch original bilder geben und
wann und von mensah der möchte wissen
warum ist das bild gerade schwarz weiß
gewesen das erste was wir gesehen haben
es wäre ja es wird noch weitere bilder
von der landung geben tatsächlich haben
diesmal kameras sowohl auf der auf dem
oberen auf der oberen hälfte der kapsel
als auch beim abstieg nachdem der
hitzeschild abgeworfen wurde komplett
die ladung aufgenommen und zwar in hoher
qualität und das ist aber so ein großes
datenvolumen dass diese bilder erst nach
und nach runtergeladen werden müssen
über die satelliten und das wird ein
paar tage wahrscheinlich dauern bis wir
das haben aber man kann sich freuen wir
freuen uns und sie können sich auch
freuen auf extrem spannende bilder und
wahrscheinlich vielleicht sogar videos
mit denen man die ganze ladung verwirrt
verfolgen können aus der perspektive des
rovers und hat es war das erste bild
gerade man hat mich auch gegen die
datenrate oder weil das war gar nichts
ich glaube das war nicht schwer das sein
oder so ein bisschen kontrast namen haus
weil eben diese diese staub schutzkappe
noch traurig war also man hat am anfang
und hatten sah es auch für die schwarz
weiß aus aber beim genaueren betrachten
und bei der zweiten ansicht dieses
bildes hat man schon gesehen ist es so
eine leichte bräunliche färbung hat und
es lag jetzt wirklich daran dass da
diese schutzkappe gut drauf war zwar
keine schwarz weiß das denke ich auch
hier ist noch eine frage auch sehr
spezifisch von jörg meyer was passierte
mit dem länder nach dem anrufer
abgesetzt hat landete er auch oder wird
einfach auf der marsoberfläche
zerschellen der skytrain also der lang
da ist ja im prinzip der skytrain der
nutzt seinen laptop letztes bisschen
treibstoff wasser übrig hat nachdem man
in europa abgesetzt hat und fliegt zur
seite weg in eine sichere entfernung
lässt dann den restlichen treibstoff ab
und wird tatsächlich zerschellen ja dann
seine mögliche hat dann quasi seine
funktion erfüllt und dann brauchen wir
nicht er hat seine aufgabe erfüllt
nicht eine frage von red crafter auch
auf youtube wurden dann bereits
bakterien gefunden beziehungsweise wird
jetzt danach gesucht
da gebe ich mal eine tochter aber nein
man hat bislang noch keine bakterien
gefunden auf dem mars und das mit
absoluter sicherheit aber genau danach
sucht man jetzt man wird allerdings also
wird jetzt keinen es gab ja in den mann
waren das in den 70er jahren mal
fehlinterpretation von seinem maß
meteoriten das war so ein langes
blümchen drin und alle dachten oh man
hat jetzt da ein bakterium auf dem mars
entdeckt ein versteinertes so wird es in
wirklichkeit nicht aussehen wonach wir
suchen sind organische verbindungen die
eben nur aufgrund von biologischer
aktivität entstanden sein können
und wenn wir glück haben stellen wir
also wenn man richtig viel glück haben
dann gibt es vielleicht so was wie
biomasse so gesteinen die nur durch die
biologische aktivität entstehen auf der
erde gibt es dafür eine ganz berühmtes
beispiel das sind diese zehn jahren
bakterien die mit so die ersten größeren
bakterienkolonien auf der erde waren die
dann auch so großen einfluss auf die
beschaffenheit unserer atmosphäre hatten
weil sie so viel sauerstoff ausgestoßen
haben so loeding erhofft man sich aber
ob es da jetzt ein kleines verstellen
dass bakterien geben wird so ähnlich
kann man sich das nicht vorstellen dass
wird er so auf molekularer und
filmischer ebene definiert werden
ganz anders wird es aussehen wenn man
den proben dann auf der erde haben dann
der sind ganz andere analyse techniken
möglich
das sind auch ganz anderen datierung
technik möglich das wird nochmal uns
sehr weit voranbringen und das ist ja
leider noch entfernen dauert noch so ich
guck mal hier bei uns in die kommentare
ich bin verwundert dass es tatsächlich
noch einige menschen gibt die denken das
ganze hier wäre also es scheint sich zu
halten dieses gerücht dass sie mit viel
aufwand und effexor betrieben wird aber
okay es gibt aber sehr viel lob und
zuspruch und begeisterung über ihre
begeisterung kann ich zurückgeben oder
weitergeben nach köln zum beispiel hier
von ilse biberti die sagt wissen und
begeisterung der wissenschaftlerin ist
wirklich genial und wir haben uns auch
gerade so gefreut darüber wie sie sich
gefreut haben dass wir das ganze noch
mal raus geschnitten haben und uns noch
mal zusammen angucken wollen das werden
sie es nicht sofort sehen können aber
auch nichts
jetzt kommt für uns
[Applaus]
die verfahren so immer wieder anziehen
das ist mal wieder eine unglaubliche
leistung der nasa diese weiche landung
auf dem neben den technischen finessen
zu schaffen das ist mir manöver was
mehrere hundert schritte erfolgt die
alle zum gleichen zum exakten zeitpunkt
ausgelöst oder passieren müssen
ja also das war ihre begeisterung vielen
dank dass sie heute abend mit uns nicht
das alles angeguckt haben uns alles so
gut erklärt haben dass wir viele fragen
beantworten könnten konnten und ich
hoffe dieser mars rover wird uns viele
spannende erkenntnisse bringen und ihm
dann auch noch viel wissenschaftliche
freude bereiten
das hoffen wir auch gerne ganz sicher
dass das zu sein wird dann würde ich
ihnen noch schönen abend nach köln und
in unserem live stream sage ich
irgendeine gleichheitssatz ist sage ich
auch vielen dank fürs zuschauen fürs
mitfiebern für die ganzen fragen und
kommentare
wir sind natürlich morgen wieder für
euch da mit einem anderen thema für
heute sage ich aber erstmal macht's gut